[Musique]
des adolescents et ils disent avoir été
humilié torturé même violet une demande
d'action collective est tentée par trois
anciens hockeyers junior lève le voile
sur un système d'initiation troublant
entre 1980 et 2014 19 joueurs ont
témoigné des civistes qu'ils ont subi
lors de leur passage dans différentes
équipes des ligues juniors de l'Ontario
de l'ouest et du Québec
[Musique]
uriner sur moi et me lancer des objets
ils ont préféré un bâton de hockey dans
mon anus ils ont recouvert les parties
génitales de crème analgésiques
chauffantes je me souviens que mon
scatum c'était atroce un autre raconte
avoir été fouettée par son entraîneur
certains auraient été agressés
la saison suivante j'ai été échangé dans
une autre équipe et j'étais agressé
sexuellement une quarantaine de fois
approximativement à l'espace de Namour
les mêmes types d'abus étaient perpétrés
dans la nouvelle quête tout ça au vu et
au sud des dirigeants des équipes
comme ça parce que c'est pas des
pratiques que moi j'ai été témoin
Gilbert Delore m'a déjà été joueur et
entraîneur dans la Ligue de hockey
junior majeur du Québec il dit ne jamais
avoir été témoin de geste aussi gras
c'est pas initié il y avait moi puis il
y avait moyen de 18 ans puis on s'est
fait avancé les cheveux puis statu après
ça on faisait partie du club
la ministre Pascal Saintonge demande la
fin des initiations je peux pas passer
mon temps à suspendre le financement
toutes les organisations la meilleure
chose à faire aujourd'hui c'est que les
adultes les organisations dans le
système sportifs envoie un message clair
comme quoi c'est interdit élevé aussi
que chaque province se date d'un
organisme indépendant pour recevoir les
plaintes comme c'est le cas au Québec
depuis deux ans que je pense que c'est
un bon pas dans la bonne direction pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait pas de
situation comme celle-là qui est plus de
situation comme celle-là mais après le
scandale de Canada il est temps de
lancer une enquête publique croit le
Bloc québécois on se rend compte que le
sport est malade puis pour moi ça
renforcer l'idée qu'il doit y avoir une
commission d'enquête publique
indépendante le juge de parcours
supérieur de l'Ontario ont rejeté la
demande de recours collectif non pas
parce qu'il ne croit pas les victimes au
contraire mais le juge que ce n'est pas
le bon véhicule judiciaire pour obtenir
indemnisation ici Jacques Audrey
Charbonneau Radio-Canada Montréal